tone it down welcome to the next episode
the 22nd episode of the corridor cast
that's right boys and girls well we're
doing this thing and today's episode
sponsor is cast box
that's right cast box is a audio
platform for podcasts it's one of the
best it's one of the fastest and it's
got everything you want on there so if
you guys like podcasts and you like
listening to them consider listening to
this one on cast box nice I have another
sponsor actually we lost sponsorship
did we is the tea tree toothpicks oh we
did lose two episodes we're sorry
responsibility yes here to tell you so I
have to apologize and they're all over
the place
yeah and now they're gone right now
they're gone forever and they'll never
be back again so thanks another either
you ought to apologize for that I'd love
to say that's one of those things we're
gonna keep apologizing for taking
responsibility
we're taking responsibility for that
constantly for everything that
conversation we had this place began
so anyways we've got Wren with us as
well today hello Wren hey how's it going
everyone mine from the other corridor
crew YouTube channel and the quartered
until YouTube channel he makes uh he's a
VFX edible content and he's a content
creator yeah ok so let's talk about a
couple different things today the first
thing on the agenda is there's a new
Bill and Ted movie happening breaking
news you'll see important starting at oh
the important stuff apparently
hammerstone Studios announced Wednesday
that production on the a third
installment of the Bill & Ted franchise
will begin this summer with Keanu Reeves
and Alex winter who are now 54 and 53
respectively reprising their roles as
metalhead slackers apparently in the new
movie and now middle-aged Bill and Ted
set off on a new adventure when a
visitor from the future it Elora
middle-aged
like late late middle-aged in a new in
the new movie a late middle aged a new
adventure when a visitor from the future
warns them that their only song can save
life as we know it and bring harmony to
the universe well the movie is set to
drop August of 2013 the second film yeah
kind of is
yeah so does the world need this and
will you see it I never saw any the
first one me neither
really first was a little Jake it was
kinda like one of those like indie films
that like it was kind of popular it's
like a terminator of the Terminator
franchise the first one the second one
bogus journey was great in my opinion I
know the memes and stuff from it and
like references but I've never actually
seen him so as they died and they go to
hell and then they're like they play
they like in the second one did manage
to escape like Satan and this is like
weird like trippy 80s hell and stuff not
like like like that and then they like
play the Grim Reaper for the life back
and like that's right yep
because you can pick three games to play
against the Grim Reaper yes I pick like
guess who checkers and like something
else one other one that he doesn't know
how to play yeah I'm a fool him yeah
anyways it gets really weird let me meet
these weird creatures yeah and then they
come back to earth and then they have a
concert where they're like fighting
robot versions of themselves that are
like playing guitar but then they also
time travel so they keep they keep doing
these things like like one guy drops a
cage and then they like oh well even
back in time we put a key in the cage
and they pulled this key like well I
went back in time I put another cage
over your cage and like it's really
trippy you remember this movie really
well III haven't seen it in about ten
years and you're bringing stuff back in
my memory now after a while like it was
on TV
like when I came home for like or was
like Saturday it was on TV and I
happened like tape it right yes right
and I washed it afterwards and like it
totally caught me by surprise
it's like the matrix when I was on an
airplane and I watched the matrix for
the first time on the airplane it's like
whoa you mean he's the one yeah they
happen to both Sartiano reeves so
calories just surprising me with good
movies here and there do that I just
write you know cuz the thing with these
movies it's like it's like are they just
gonna be man children in this like they
are and
dumb and dumber to situation yeah cuz
like I started watching some of those
Will Ferrell movies that I'd missed like
you know stepbrothers and stuff and
there's some funny stuff in there but
it's also really weird because they're
man children do you think they'll
address like what happens to the so in
the in the previous one they were like
teenage or early 20s metalheads do you
think they'll address what happens to
somebody that's a metalhead in their
teens and 20s when George Carlin said he
was like they're like right there dad
yeah you're right like are they gonna
show what leading a responsible adult
life is like after yeah it's like
enjoying metal and you're twenty still
is an insurance agent and ted's he's a
music teacher yeah music teacher yeah
they own a metal label I'm like 60
percent sure it's based on a comic book
by the way anyway will you guys see this
that's pretty high probability
I may be probably not see it but I'm not
opposed to seeing I'll probably like
pick it up on a red box or something I
know okay watching DVD it's good reviews
no blu-rays dude look at watching HD
DVDs man
I prefer renting blu-rays over extreme
why don't you just rent something on
Amazon
cuz it's streaming rights go to the
blocks I water watching movies that are
50 gigabytes as opposed to one mm-hmm
but why can't see I'm just I like I like
having the visual clarity mmm sounds
like and it's like it's it's super cheap
it's cheaper to rent a blu-ray than it
is to rent something off of Amazon it's
like it was a third of the price it's
like $2 grand I think are you the kind
of guy who sets your TVs sharpening to a
hundred percent no do you have motion
interpolation turn on your TV Hale no no
God well you don't even have a T that
should be brought up at all times a
screen except you're playing video games
yeah but the fact that that's the
default setting what's worse than old
people don't know how to turn it off
enabling that feature and that's
becoming more and more of a thing over
the last couple years you don't even
have to turn the TV off after like five
minutes it automatically turns it back
on why I don't know why I would break my
TV yeah yeah
TV big chain everyone's against us man a
man trying to make that footage smooth
alright moving on we can we talk about
the new VR headset that was announced
we're gonna get into Nika wants to do a
couple more warm-up laps before we get
into them go ahead alright so the rift s
was announced recently and if you guys
are familiar with the current VR market
you basically have the vibe you have the
oculus rift which are for all intents
and purposes kind of the same thing
basically said things are gonna watch
your headset and then your headset is
tracked in 3d space the difference is
that the oculus requires cameras or as
the vibe just says he's like laser
emitters and all the cameras are built
on the headset there's been Windows
mixed reality headsets kind of coming
out over the past couple months that are
basically there's no things you set up
for tracking all the cameras are built
into the headset it's just doing
real-time 3d tracking they came same
kind of real-time 3d tracking you
basically can get with your phone when
you do like do like an augmented reality
thing with your phone so oculus recently
announced the rift S which is basically
the same thing as the oculus rift except
instead of using cameras plugged into
your computer it has the cameras on the
headset and it's doing inside out
tracking so it's basically doing the
same thing alone is doing there's been a
couple other basic changes like they
switch the lens type the head strap is
like the head strap on the PlayStation
VR good like it the screens are longer
oh LED it sells LCD it's a slightly
higher resolution but for all intents
and purposes like these things are kind
of lateral moves and of course of course
when something like this is announced
every single VR enthusiasts out there
who owns an oculus like what this isn't
an upgrade I was expecting better oculus
Facebook doesn't care about VR oculus
might as well just throw it in the
garbage I waited three years for this
screw this it's just a downgrade and
like of course it's just all complaints
and don't get it they don't don't get it
they want better content but they only
want it for like they're there anymore
yeah why are some more roads built from
my Lamborghinis
I mean that's more or less an accurate
statement
so Nikko why is that a like a
misinterpretation of what's important
about this yes what about this like
first off there's nothing that's really
a downgrade on the headset everything's
either a slight upgrade or just kind of
a lateral move which is my new favorite
thing to say a lot like going from an
LED screen that's slightly lower
resolution to an LCD screen it's
slightly higher resolution is more or
less a lateral move you trade off good
black levels for more resolution etc
what's sorry well what's the price on
the roof desks or hundred bucks that's
great
yeah that's great great so here's the
thing setting up cameras is the worst
and you guys might think it's fine if
you have a rift and that's cool but in
reality it's actually the worst yeah
first off if your computer doesn't have
good USB ports three of them or two of
them if you undo room-scale
you gotta get an expensive USB card you
gotta be troubleshooting it I've had
plenty of threads of people that
struggle with this stuff so setting up
cameras is worse and not to mention like
I have my vive upstairs I use it once in
a while but honestly it's incredibly
inconvenient to use because every time I
want to use it I gotta go and I got put
everything out I got to set it all up I
gotta do room scale again it's annoying
as heck first is just being able to plug
in my headset put it on and start that's
wonderful and I don't care if everything
else is the same just being able to plug
it in and turn it on is great and for
the vast majority of people out there
who want to do VR they aren't they can't
deal with setting up cameras and they
can't deal with troubleshooting 3 USB
3.0 ports and their computer they just
you need like at this point you can run
VR on most machines it's like if they're
coming out with a quest which is
basically on a mobile phone VR games are
gonna work on most machines but the
issue is getting three USB 3.0 ports
it's like power your three cameras and
then getting cables along you have to
stretch the other side of the room
that's not gonna happen for 99 percent
of people out there
so what oculus has done is I've made a
headset that's basically the same as the
oculus rift in terms of your VR
experience but you don't need cameras to
track it you don't need vibes
lighthouses to track it it's just a
self-contained headset you plug it in
and you start playing so it's easier to
use and it's cheaper and this means the
price is the reference okay I mean sure
but like cheaper than when it first came
out they're like right hundred dollars
six hundred dollars
my point is that it's cheap enough that
your average Joe can go out and like
kind of buy one now it's a big console
price but it's not like you know they're
buying a thousand dollar computer it's
it's myself no I just I'm shaking my
head because I think it's funny how this
is like a topic that people find
controversial in any manner Wells cuz
they wanted to have a better headset
they want to have a big upgrade they
want to have 8k per Ayad Ayana but they
want to be probably cheaper somehow -
yeah we're gonna bring more people to VR
which is gonna encourage more developers
to make VR games and just kind of push
the entire industry forward and that's
why I'm excited yeah same reason why I'm
excited about the one will pint it's
gonna bring more people to writing one
wheels that's why I don't play video
games in my face cuz I don't want to
deal with setting up cameras yeah yeah I
mean the biggest issues of VR right now
it's not really your headset resolution
I mean that'd be nice having more
resolution the biggest issues of VR
right now is the tracking and the
software people want the Nintendo switch
in VR form but the problem is that the
technology is 20 years behind yeah and
so it you'd need that time I mean
honestly the conversation that you're
seeing right now that's which is a great
analogy because the conversation you're
seeing right now is the exact same thing
like when the switch came on it's like
the switch it's so underpowered look at
it's so tiny and who would take that to
a party I got my playstation 4 why isn't
it switched better than the PlayStation
4 it's like well no there are different
goals different things yeah it's like
this is going to make VR way more
accessible for everybody that has a
gaming computer well what do you think
about the oculus quest then which is
basically the same thing but it's
entirely self-contained
anna has positional track I love the
idea of the oculus quest from a hardware
point of view like that's that's the end
goal you don't need a computer just put
your headset on and you go that's
awesome yeah I don't love the idea that
a I can't plug it into my computer take
you know basically just run it like a
regular headset where I can have better
graphics and B it's really it's Facebook
just trying to pull an Apple Apple Store
kind of thing where what they really
want with ACOs Quest is their walled
garden where you have to buy every game
from their store which is kind of same
thing going out the Nintendo switch or
you know anything like that but like
what they're doing with that like
there's no more I can't put mods and
beat saver to play my own custom songs
in the quest you know now it's all deal
see them I'll have to pay play for I
can't you know load up little email I
owe games hold on you're starting to
comply
about the roads not being good for your
Lamborghini natural concern for the
quest by all your software from the
oculus store of course but that's not a
problem though like on my playstation I
always just buy all my games to the
PlayStation hold online yeah okay so
Nintendo has that walled garden but the
thing is we know that deep down Nintendo
has this pure soft friendly innocent
heart and all the games stem from that
that feeling I mean look at Facebook
it's like what kind of games are they
gonna have in their walls yeah people in
the garden through the backdoor and
you're gonna know they're there yeah
exactly I think the other thing too is
like they're also gonna sell your head
movement becomes the thing that is gonna
be sold through true guarantee you like
did you look at where on the ad did you
look well it's all YouTube it's gonna
know all that and they're gonna sell
that information I think it's fantastic
that YouTube finally has that though
with their like the YouTube studio just
how many times has your thumbnail been
shown to someone and how many times have
they clicked on it it's like we're
that's so close to like that idata
yeah you know and yeah it's fascinating
oh man those red arrows can't we just
see more of those but I think the end of
the day they're like with the the whole
Walt garden thing with VR being as young
as it is there's so many great
experiences that aren't polished final
games that you can get on the PC that
realistically I feel like what you're
gonna get the most of in the oculus
store is like the wave shooters that are
super polished you know versus like
really cool experimental but unfinished
things which i think is where the most
fun in VR lies these days you're not
gonna get that with the quest but those
are more in depth like experiences right
it's like isn't the quest about bringing
bringing a vr gaming to a much larger
audience so you don't really need the
really games you're gonna play on the
quest aren't gonna be like you don't
know that though you're not you don't
know that the game I mean they kind of
know it that's not necessarily it's like
it doesn't have to be that way you're
gonna get your space pirate trainer
remix you're gonna get your beat saver
with the same ten songs been playing and
maybe five new ones and guess what those
are actually great games for someone
who's never
vr truer true but you'll play space
pirate Rainer for like a day
you play it'd be cheaper for more than a
day be there is great yeah but you'll
play space pirate Rainer for a day you
like okay that's neat but it's the
equivalent of writing a jet ski yeah
it's neat you'll do it once or twice and
then it'll sit in your dock like owning
a jetski I seek out of jet skis it's
like owning up frequently it's yeah yeah
yeah I'm being a little harsh in the
quest but Oh harsh the at the end of the
day like the Virtual Boy but just better
graphics it's really just it's a wait to
see what what great story based RPGs
they're on the Virtual Boy it's a
wait-and-see kind of thing with software
cuz yeah for now there's actually not a
lot of games worth buying on the switch
mm-hmm okay I mean it's something that
you've had in son hump cart hardcore of
a gamer you are only actually only like
five or six that's about how much I have
it yes but that's what I say a whole
console so I'm looking for the next
thing now since Smash Brothers nothing's
really catching me you know so it was
Dark Souls
maybe when the new Zelda comes out the
link to the password but here's the
thing
that's the one of games like I'm still
playing that switch every single day
yeah it's crazy I've been I've been
playing that as much if not more than my
PC I just picked up Sid six for the iPad
and that is a leisurely game if I've
ever played one before Wow
sit on the couch and pull inerrant
hexagons and nooks at Gandhi I don't
know why more doors haven't smartened up
and ported their stuff to iPad because
like an encoder or like even these like
story based like adventure games like
even like the old Lucas Lucas games or
whatever what are they called LucasArts
games LucasArts yeah like stuff like
that like gosh I mean Grim Fandango is
on their impending was a great
experience
oh great inside is an iPad and if you
haven't played inside and you own an
iPad buy it right now inside inside it's
also a great honor to see it's a good be
great to play on your projector
trust me it's so good okay
dude it's the moodiest coolest it's like
it's like it's like a storybook except
you're playing stories I'm already
uninterested
let's talk about a MOBA let's talk about
videos online and whether they're good
or bad okay
yeah that's kind of what we do I know
that's why it's relevant to this podcast
yeah so this is this is this is a
heavier topic YouTube and Facebook have
defended themselves in response to the
Christchurch attack videos if you all
are probably familiar with at this point
last Friday the Christchurch MOG
shootings or mosque shootings were live
streamed online and YouTube and Facebook
have defended themselves against policy
makers who accused them of failing to
act quickly enough stating that their
moderation is as good as possible given
the number of videos uploaded so here's
some stats that came out on Tuesday
Facebook stated that while the original
stream was viewed live fewer than 200
times and non live by 4,000 people
before it was removed copies of it
spread so rapidly that by Saturday
evening they had removed more than 1.5
million reuploads youtubers forced to
remove human review from the takedowns
due to the fact that quote the volume
this is from somebody at YouTube the
volume of related YouTube videos
uploaded oh sorry the volume of related
videos uploaded to YouTube within the
first 24 hours after the attack was
unprecedented at times as fast as a new
upload every second so there's a lot of
issues we could get into there there but
my main one that I want to ask is that
the real issue seems to be why would so
many people try to re-upload this what
does that say and is that possible
grounds for more moderation in digital
media I guess the question is is it news
or is it people trying to get views
that's what I'm saying like why would
one point five million people re-upload
this by Saturday evening on Facebook
after only 200 people saw it live yeah I
think
it's interesting that thought process
the thought process from you seeing it
for the first time whether you're
horrified or you're shocked or you what
I mean who knows but like sure some
people are why would you reload that
video other than just for the like
immediate goal of alerting authorities
you know to mean like obviously okay
yeah I see a bad video I need to get it
out so people are aware that this
happened I mean I see there's two things
one you just want to horrify in shock or
the people aka it's the same thing
reason you send them anything else it
stimulates people's emotions but just
one just being more extreme or be I mean
isn't they talk about glorifying you
know people in their acts of mass
violence that people do acts of mass
violence to get attention for what it's
worth we uploading the video you're
giving them attention I have not seen
the video should pop up at all I've not
seen it I'm not even send me the video
I've no idea what the shooters face
looks like I have no idea what his name
is
and normally that's fairly rare I've
seen none of that so one and a half
million uploads of this videos never
crossed my path that's what I'm saying
is like they this is policy makers have
looked at them and they've said you got
I mean honestly it's kind of a it's just
a situation that allows them to say
something they've been wanting to say
the whole time which is digital media
needs to be regulated and this is just a
this is just a catalyst that allows them
to say that but the fact that these many
uploads happened and none of us here saw
I mean we didn't seek them out there's a
pretty good job that's incredibly a new
upload every second onto your site and
you have robots that just go in and it's
just like turn off you know like that's
amazing the fact that that that that
they can control it to that degree of
specificity now and I think this is a
good thing they're doing I think YouTube
doesn't want people like YouTube as a
company should never want people to be
uploading videos like this now because
really if it's the day after a couple we
like up to he'll even like a year after
that's all glorifying the act it's not
historical at that point like down the
line shirt like you can let it date
historical thing for reference but right
now if there's one point five million
people uploading it it's a bit of a lie
that's the exact kind of buzz like if
you're uploading that video you are
doing exactly what that shooter wanted
you to do and you're kind of a piece of
[ __ ]
so I'm just going to say that thinking
beyond your axe there you need to think
deeper than what you're doing it alright
you can be making the argument that
you're trying to preserve it for news
that's fine leave it on your hard drive
for a month a year or whatever and then
if you need to archive it and put it out
there for people to reference sure but
right now yeah you just cook you just
grab those views and trying to shock
your friends and that's kind of [ __ ]
turning around you're uploading it the
next day because you know people are
going to be searching for it and you
want to get views that's wrong yeah yeah
but I well it's probably a certain
number of people who are doing that I I
don't know if that's you know what I for
some reason my optimistic side is like
there's no way that that could be the
majority of why people are do it you
don't think that's like oh I can make
money off of this video I first I feel
like deep down inside I don't feel like
that's the driving goal of the majority
of those reuploads so what agree with
that yeah I mean there's morbid
curiosity for morbid curiosity awareness
but you don't need a satisfy that morbid
curiosity by glorifying a killer the
moment it happens okay yeah I said well
I guess that's the thing there's a
reload glorify just by just a neutral
upload I drag a file and a hit I hit
upload is that that I just glorified
something I mean you're being way
abstract here the day after it happens
yes okay well yes
horrifying at that day after it happens
you're going out of your way to give
power to that person this also brings up
a thing do you think that for examples
the people that did this and committed
this do you think that their names and
faces should be even reported okay yeah
it's like it's like when they don't show
a streaker at a video at a at a sports
event mmm now this is obviously a much
more horrific version of that but yeah
don't give the same attention here I get
that I get that I mean wait you get that
but answer Jake's question my question
is do you think that the names and faces
of the people that commit these sort of
acts should be publicly stated well
here's here's this some I mean first off
obviously hold on hold on yeah this is
complex it is because there's a really
bad sounding thought experiment that I'm
putting myself through recently here
when I after hearing about this story
because the common narrative has in in
media and with people has been when
something really bad happens like clamp
down on it ignore it pretend it doesn't
happen don't share it don't give them
the attention
let's cetera etc because that is
supposed to psychologically counteract
or discourage other people from doing
horrific things I think that's pretty it
over the last decade or so it's kind of
risen in popularity to where I think
it's now that's that's what everyone
says and once again it's like I don't I
don't like watching violent videos I
don't like seeing this stuff like I
don't think people should do it but at
the same time there's a part of me where
it's like I think particularly
particularly here in the United States
you know everyone jokes about thoughts
and prayers like very frequently like
you'd see people say thoughts and
prayers and that became a meme okay that
became a meme as a response to something
horrific and tragic happening right and
well people criticize the thoughts and
prayers because thoughts and prayers
don't do anything all you're doing is
you're you're not basically ignoring it
and moving on until the next one happens
because you're not contributing anything
and more and more as I think about that
once again this is particularly in the
United States not things than like New
Zealand because their response was fast
they're like boom things are banned boom
no guns
boom action taken okay but here in the
United States it's something that
happens way more regularly than in New
Zealand and Australia and so as I was
saying so get back on that thread
thoughts and prayers has been now now a
meme because of its ineffective 'ti
effectively yeah
but then at the same time you have this
other response which is ignore it
hide the names hide the faces talk about
it but like basically we're we're
cutting off all the edges here of this
discussion is just saying something
really bad happened and and and and I
think I just this is the thought
experiment but is the inaction in the
United States on these mass tragedies
partially due to the fact that people
aren't getting the skit like the [ __ ]
scared out of them you know what I mean
doing the like cuz you know like if you
see there's something crazy online you
see a violent video you walk away with
like that like weird scared adrenaline
I'm like oh my god life is so so many
dentists are so important you know and
so like like valuable and one you made
an assertion you said people are getting
the [ __ ] scared out of them that's a
false assertion well if I I feel like I
mean the Sandy Hook shooting was awful
every knows is awful and they don't need
a video to know is awful well I know but
but then why why did does this keep
happening you know well because people
don't feel like there's a lot of reasons
why they these things keep happening but
it's not like you can boil it down to
one particular thing I mean it's a it's
a it's a host of issues that's not I'm
not trying to say this is the only
reason I agree it's a big host of issues
it's a lot of things but is this one of
them you know talk about these shootings
because of that but it's like we still
we're the events themselves are still
reported on they're still talked about
quite a bit yeah but there's a it's a
bit more of a recent push than I think
you're letting on of not specifically
not showing two things the face in the
name yeah I don't think we should ignore
them at all I'm just saying it's like
giving credit to the person and putting
their name out there like Timothy
McVeigh everyone's heard that guy's name
because these the Unabomber yeah he's
the guy that blew up the city the
Unabomber is a different guy yeah
whatever
you get my point
but that's my point is people everyone
knows their name John Wayne Gacy you
know like all these all these horrible
people now if you don't give them that
satisfaction which is the satisfaction
that they want ultimately that's all I
think I'm trying to say yeah but well I
guess I guess my my point is being
derived more from the response to like
Australia and I guess that here's the
other difference sorry
I want to answer your questions you did
pose a question here and I do want it I
want to throw out my two cents on it
it's one thing to show a video that say
somebody else filmed from outside of
like the aftermath or something like
that like in the Paris nightclub
shooting you had video people took at
the street of like the SWAT team is
getting ready to enter the building for
example yeah yes another thing to show
the killer's
own video that he'd livestream or he's
making quips and jokes and talking about
stuff like don't play his video
don't play the killers propaganda okay
so news is one yeah you can show the
news you know you can show like the
aftermath you can show footage other
people might have gotten of the moment
their experiences the horror but don't
don't glorify the killer's his own like
the killer's own propaganda his own
video his own attention you're giving
power yeah I'm him or her when that
happens
I've only usually it's a very lightly
that was like that's the actual response
to me she wasn't on experiment that's
the actual like what you just said is
the first answer I think I've heard to
that because you know once again I
haven't seen this dish I haven't seen
the [ __ ] and I like so it's it's a thing
where it's like you hear it's like oh I
can imagine
death I guess in violence but I can't
imagine like all these weird super
jacked up things that you're mentioning
like big constant like I did hear that
mean thing or like this quip thing it's
like I don't know what is in contained
within it but yeah but you're right if
it's like from that perspective of if
it's part of this killers propaganda it
kind of belongs in that camp but yeah
yeah versus just the concept of general
awareness of what death and tragedy
there's nothing wrong but curiosity yeah
either like that's part of being human
yeah exactly confronting death like I
think reddit banning this
watch people die like they were using
this as an excuse to ban that sub most
people weren't going there to like get
off and watch people die people are
going there to understand death like
it's part of it's part of the human
experience yes that's the topic I'm
mostly talking to but it's like this do
we see like is that facet of this
conversation playing into the United
States is ineffective attending the
situation properly I don't know is that
I know that's big I do think though on
that reddit banning that that subreddit
I mean morbid curiosity yes everyone as
like you know considered Oh what what
does a dead person look like right
but unfettered access to that at a young
age I think could be damaging I think
that like like sex ad or other topics it
needs to be done in a sort of
constructive environment perhaps they
should even like have a class on like
death in general for kids so that they
understand what it is in a in a
constructive manner rather than just
like here's a bunch of images of people
dying on on the Internet
he's a shockingly yeah watch at I mean I
remember the first time me and my buddy
snuck to the video store and somehow we
got a copy of faces of death mm-hmm and
I was like 10 and it was way too much
for me at the time and I never wanted to
see anything like that ever again yeah
so something about that VHS like filter
eyes like just like so horrible it's
fake right but I didn't know right and
then and then the other thing is like
that could have had just an opposite
effect on me if I would have just had
like a couple things in my brain wired
slightly differently you know now sudden
instead of me never wanting to see it
again I'm now all this sudden obsessed
with it and just I think you know maybe
that's an argument for why they you know
banning things like that is not a bad
idea but yeah anyway I think yeah
there's a lot there's a lot of questions
there that will never be answered but I
think my point that I wanted to make
with bringing up this topic was just
like let's ask ourselves why so many
people would want to reload that
and and maybe consider if if there's
small things that can be done
differently like maybe not using the
people's names or faces and things like
that that might help alleviate some of
this yeah I feel like that's a small
thing that goes a really long way it's
like a small little thing just don't say
the name don't show the picture the
person's face and it's like I feel like
it's such a small act that does so much
more than the actual effort in order to
do it yeah right I think one thing
you're saying that's interesting too is
you're seeing a cultural shift around
that like people are becoming aware of
don't say the name don't say the face
and that's like spreading more and more
and at the end of the day it's cultural
shifts I talked about this before
yes but it's cultural shifts that cause
a change it's not government regulations
it's not Facebook policies like what
actually causes a shift is people going
you know what I'm not gonna share that
video I'm not gonna watch the video I'm
not gonna seek it out I'm not gonna talk
about it I'm not gonna give power to
that person
it's that cultural shift that actually
changes things and that's what needs to
spread you can try to make all the rules
you want in the world at the end of the
day like human beings like they're going
to do their we make our own rules yeah
man
there's this human nature and like you
can try to make as many rules against
human nature as you want but it's not
until like human culture shifts that
human nature can become something
different totally all right let's talk
about something happy let's talk about
something lighter here's a things in the
world are good that's actually more
people in the world are doing good
things every single day so don't get
reported yeah doing doing fun and
exciting there's one thing they're most
likely surviving them right so Lilly
Singh White Plains we all know her as
Superman on YouTube here yes sorry
superwoman was selected to host a
late-night NBC show that will replace
the Carson Daly's last call which is
going off the air after 17 years the
lateral move nikko upgrade so the new
shows reported around 1/2 hour will
include interviews as well as pre-taped
segments and comedy sketches and it
makes sing one of a few women in history
to host a late
program on a broadcast network I'm all
about this I think this is really cool I
think this is fantastic on almost every
single look yeah like she not only is
she she's she knows what the YouTube
grind is you know she started just like
everyone else she like has a loyal
audience that and she makes stuff that's
actually creative and yeah I've never
met her personally but everything that
yes she's I mean she's talented and
witty yeah she seems like this seems
like a really cool thing and I think
it's also just another big step in the
blending of traditional and digital
media which eventually those terms will
go away I think entirely I do think he
was a very smart move on NBC's part to
bring her on hey what are the kids doing
oh they're watching this superwoman she
does this with her fingers it's just
like every once in a while like those
people those like those those those gray
you know elderly like executives you
know they make a good move yeah totally
unlike the guys at the Oscars yeah
that's pretty cool though it's pretty
sweet yeah I think it's good for
everyone like you know just having
having to access now for people like us
are other people in you know in our
community having access to her having up
having that platform as well you know
it's just yeah just so it goes to show
you you can be a youtuber and talented
at the same right even though she's
Canadian I feel like this is like a this
is like the epitome of the American
dream right here so anyway I think it's
cool you don't have to be American to be
the epitome of the American dream that's
true that's part of that's part of the
American dream right
[Laughter]
oh wow all right you guys want to talk
about we're gonna talk about both of
these but do you want to talk about
project stadia first or yes the second
time we're gonna be an interesting
copyright thing project stadia all right
so I'm I'm pretty excited about this I
think this will be cool someone
explained yes yes go meet gay Phil
Harrison who used to work for I think it
was Sony has now been working for Google
and leading this project and project
stadium was basically you guys remember
OnLive back in the day so on live was
like a little box you put in your TV and
when it would stream you're basically
okay I'm doing a horrible job like
Netflix for games well no what does that
mean like twitched heck no here's a lot
work suffer playing your computer is
stored at Google's data center your
controller is at your house and what
happens is you hit your input your
controller it goes into your Wi-Fi it
goes to the internet it goes to their
data center it changes something on the
computer and it sends back your image so
basically imagine your console being
really far away in someone else's
network hub but that's basically what
projects they do live sucked because the
latency sucked mm-hmm and that is kind
of the issue with all online gaming yeah
latency yes because you're waiting for
your signal to go all the way out there
hit their computer get rendered and come
all the way back and get displayed and
how is this different so Google as you
might know owns the Internet basically
they have a lot of server a little
facetious here but Google has a lot of
network infrastructure so they're
getting around all the different hops
and changes and connections that you
have to do and they're just straight
pipe in it right to their server and
here's the other thing you might imagine
they're like oh when you send a signal
that's like go to the other side of like
America the reality is that Google is a
data center probably within a 50 mile
radius of where you are no matter where
you are in America there's I think 7500
or 6500 data centers really the mayor
yeah in America Wow so every single city
basically has one it um so at that point
all you're doing when you're hitting a
button it's just like if we're here in
our studio and we wanted to use it it's
just go into a data center it's maybe a
mile away in downtown and coming back
it's probably a data center we film sync
at yeah so it's really not going that
far and then Google has the network
infrastructure to directly send it right
there without hopping between a bunch of
different hubs so it becomes a lot
faster I've heard the latency is like 20
to 30 milliseconds and just for
reference a frame at 60 frames per
second is 16 milliseconds so you're
basically one frame behind your video
game which is more or less unnoticeable
the thing is most people don't realize
this but if you have your video game
console hooked up your TV with HDMI
you're like 70 to 200 milliseconds
behind yeah I've played on some TVs that
just have really slow processing speeds
so it's like the input lag from your
controller you press up it's awful but
people didn't really notice until they
got Guitar Hero and sec huh I'm missing
a lot of notes on this TV for something
so project stadia is basically like
letting you not have to own a computer
or not have to own a console you just
own your controller and it connects to
your Wi-Fi and then you play from that
and gets piped to your chromecast
whatever new TV this phone or your iPad
or your laptop any screen basic yeah you
can hop to it so you imagine you're
playing your TV like pause and you grab
the controller you go into your like
kitchen and you open your iPad hit play
and then it just pops with an iPad and
you keep playing that's pretty neat
that's really cool but it's kind of been
done before I like that story though
this is what happened there so you were
playing on your TV and you just got
kicked off bhatia and now you have to
play on your iPad in the kitchen alone
[Laughter]
there's online so like what makes us
different outside well one it's the
latency and the fact that Google has a
really fast infrastructure but to
there's a couple other really unique
things happening here and this is what
really starts to make it special
first off your game state is being
constantly saved so that's kind of like
the same of having a quicksave that's
going all the time just quick save quick
save quick save quick save quick save
it's just all being logged and so
imagine if you will you're watching
shroud play pub gee well actually they
would work as multiplier game imagine if
you will you're watching me and Sam at
node playing Resident Evil 2 the remake
on PC and we're getting this big boss
fight it's getting really crazy we've
got bunch of rockets and we're about to
get in in this awesome showdown you're
like boy that looks fun and then you
click on it and you go to the exact
moment in the game on your stadia set up
and start playing it because any save
state you can load up so it's like
having a timecode stamp like a video but
for a video game so you just jump right
to that moment and start playing right
from that moment it do it the exact same
settings the exact the people that are
in a game that could be pretty no you
can do with multiplayer ok seems like
it's really good that like crazy story
based games where people are about to
make a decision don't do it like you can
hop in and see what happens yeah new
decision but you can't hop in with the
person that's you know a single player
no no no it's basically just like
watching a game video and then just
suddenly you're playing it so it'll give
you all the same things that happened
prior to that moment yeah woah it's like
literally just stealing their game
saving the water yeah and that same
wonder that you know here's something
funny that yeah you know like
twitchplayspokemon like how they had
this thing where there's like this group
based game that was going mm-hmm you
could probably do something really funny
like that where you everyone it's like
musical games basically we have a save
state that's being streamed you know and
it's being passed around to like random
users that's get to make decisions like
one one button that one button press at
a time or something maybe cool you know
maybe this person has five seconds to do
what when's this coming out I don't know
do you guys wanna hear the dark side of
stadia always what's up what's up lift
up those servers what's underneath I
mean they are doing something
interesting here with the controller so
they've designed their own new control
you can continue to use USB controllers
from any other game console from the
last ten years or whatever but the
stadia controller is specifically
hooking up to the server directly
through Wi-Fi it's not actually
connecting to your chromecast your
laptop or whatever it's completely
separate and it's communicating directly
with the Google servers to decrease that
lag even further just crazy
so I was like okay that's I mean the
main reason why I've never really been
interested in online game streaming
because it's like the latency is not
there but if it is there and I could
just like pull out my phone and have
like a great high quality PC gaming
experience just like all I have to do is
have the internet it's like I think
that's pretty interesting but now I'm
interested in hearing the dark side a
dark side dark side imagine if you will
a subscription style platform for
playing video games like YouTube or they
encourage you to create the most to
watch time but instead it's playtime for
a video game which I guys gets the most
playtime it's the biggest slice of the
ad revenue and subscription revenue it's
a baby's buddy making the biggest grind
fest with the best little like skinner
box loot boxes to just suck away as many
minutes from people as they can is going
to make the most revenue because they
want you to stay on the platform as long
as possible imagine for a second if
you'll be incentivizing people to make
destiny but less fun exactly okay we've
already seen a translations in fortnight
we've already seen the kind of filler
that you get on YouTube with how the
algorithm promoted watch time there's no
such thing as a tutorial it's two
minutes long every tutorial is huge in
every video has filler even our videos
have some filler but we've gotten way
better at that our videos are actually
mostly killer now do something about
that though if it starts to ruin the
platform yep it's optimism here coming
in here not to complain it's phases its
phases yeah well still making in them on
the platform as long as possible so they
go to as many as I mean talk show hosts
like easy to produce per minute Derek's
going to lead to a promotion of a
certain type of game which is a
easy-goin time sucker but it was too far
people will people will revolt right and
then they'll pull it back and we'll find
that nice middle ground but here's what
it really in here's why I'm worried
about I don't play video games to kill
time I don't have time to kill I don't
like killing time you're killing a
little bit of yourself when you kill
time that's really deep guy so you can
on the tracks get out of the way my
trains getting in here this is one of
those trains to run over the penny just
like the Nikko train all the train cars
did you guys set out pennies and
motional simulation games to move me and
be mostly fulfilling and you don't do
that by having me sit on the couch and
grind away for hours on end that sounds
like the Stanley parable games in the
world but it's the same thing like oil
yeah okay eventually when all the cars
are electric
people will still buy oil but it'll be
like super expensive and you'll buy it
in the little jar right so you'll use it
for the 1905 T Model T that yeah I'll to
wait for a little like per you know
that's all plastic yeah I just I'm not a
huge fan of like the destiny's des amis
now no I think those games are stupid
and they're lame and they're for kids
because it's like his kids want to kill
time girls want to kill what's your
optimistic point now this Sam I'm not
buying it I think it's gonna come in two
phases in waves like things get popular
and then they don't get popular and P
sick leave that over safe they over
saturate the market the one like a cool
story based RPG like experimental thing
that comes out that year he's gonna blow
up or like be popular and then people
are going oh oh let's just make
something else now like it still happens
like right now like we're suing we're
still seeing tons of like incredible
games coming out better experimental or
emotional making me cry you know made
you cry a game has made you cry before I
don't know let me think Smash Brothers
Sam weeping minutes ago I didn't wipe
the tears away from my little screen you
were weeping red and took his Bowser and
tackle Sam right off the edge and I won
because both of them only had one stop
was crying the only game that made me
cry ever was uh oh the Last Guardian as
a cry for game alright alright how long
how much longer do you think the battle
royale genre is gonna continue trekking
away I mean how long I mean yes FPS is
here to stay
I don't think anyone understood what
made pubsey effective I think everyone
got it wrong okay I think explosions
legions yes
hey big sledge this is a different style
game that's the thing it's like they're
it's quote-unquote battle royale stay
with four night quote unquote battle
royale for tonight gets a little bit of
it right but I think epics legends is
like pub she's a little bit different
pubs you create more of a story when you
play it and hey guys we talk about video
games for a second year here we go with
all with basically video game shooters
there's one style format that you stuck
with for years and years and years Halo
kind of followed the same gameplay loop
Call of Duty follow the same gameplay
loop and made even better and like other
video games came out and follow the same
gameplay loop which is give you cool
guns give you cool tactics have things
be slightly unbalanced when you go into
a situation it's interesting and pop pop
pop bang bang bang see who wins do it
again
great counter-strike there you start it
done yeah exactly counter-strike started
here's the issue tactics for gunplay and
video games when you don't value your
character's life tactics are very
different you becomes a twitch fest
becomes jump in writing from the other
guy he's done the same thing and so you
can twitch the fastest or so you can
have the best positioning when somebody
runs into a room pub she changed that
pub she was inspired by Daisy because
Daisy kind of kicked this off which was
hey what if your characters died forever
when you died
how would you play a shooter then you
wouldn't run into a room to see how many
people you can drop before you go down
she would play it very very differently
yeah and when you create value for the
character's life it changes how you
approach a situation tactically and
honestly that's kind of how what makes
it gunfight more interesting is not how
twitchy you can be but how can you
approach a situation to get out there
with
getting shot in select crates very
different tactics it creates very
different ways you position yourself it
creates different very different ways
you approach a situation with friends
because it's not you know who can go in
there Rambo the quickest and go out and
biggest blaze of glory so this was
happening in Daisy but the prom with
Daisy is that you have to wait like four
hours before we could get into like a
real fight because they said go find
other stuff and then if you died or the
game glitched out it was a pain in the
ass
and then they basically basically took
that concept is actually player unknown
Brandon or whatever his name is he had
played the that's like that it wasn't
the Hunger Games as a survivor games
from Daisy and he got inspired he's like
this like has people value their life it
has people treat gunfights completely
differently and that's your benefit
tactically your your experience in a
gunfight is always different because not
just playing the same map I'm not just
doing de dust2 over and over and over
because the fights boil down to a
different area of the map every time and
tactically you have to approach it
differently every time Cellini went off
and he made the Battle Royale mod for
ARMA which is more or less the same
things what you play in pub GP these
days in that circle when they close in
different areas would force you to
approach the fights differently are you
fighting the valley between two
mountains are you fighting in a city are
you fighting on the coast each one of
those is a different way of how you have
to approach battle and on top of that
you have value for your character's life
it's not just to go out there in games
when it kills as you can so that got
brought into pub G and what it led to is
it creates a story when you play the
video game you're emotionally involved
in the game you're you have this
dramatic adventure you go through as you
go through the hills and you find your
cars and your guns and you fight your
way to eventually winning the game in a
game like apex legends still a super fun
game it's not really about this dramatic
emotional story apex Legends is starting
to blur the line back between getting
back into like the instant action get
into some quick fights but you still
have a little bit of the emotional
journey of a battle royale game but it's
not it's not going in the direction that
pub G was pushing games towards whereas
I think something like escape from
tarkov
this pubs you taken even further into
the like emotional rawness so I never
got into this I think that's why I never
got into like pub G or tarkoff for that
matter it's like I didn't have the
patience for it is like I totally
understand the feeling of you know
for the the story and the adventure and
the experience you get from that but I
part of means also is like I just want
to jump in and shoot some people and
then like jump around and then it's
really cool I do
yeah I think I mean everybody has the
different types of games but I think
Battle Royale is not just about going in
shooting people as fast as you can and
hope that your last one alive just kind
of what like Call of Duty's Battle
Royale like push towards there's a
little bit what apex legends pushes
towards it's like it infects legends
pushes more towards team play actually I
didn't like any other Battle Royale game
and it's just like it
apex legends has the teamplay aspect
more motivated and promoted it also has
the tactical like each tactical
engagement is different because of how
the areas you're getting pushed into is
different it so has those aspects like
pubs you taken over it doesn't really
have the like I'm going on a long
journey I really value my characters
life I've been investing this for half
an hour it doesn't really have that
going on for it you can die your
teammates can go to a little thing and
revive you with your cell phone you know
but that's cool like they at least
they're experimenting with the formula
which is awesome yeah yeah speaking of
video games the Des Moines police
department played a real-life video game
this week when they were assisting the
fire department during let a cig
building fire and officers rescued three
small children from the fire by
instructing the mother to drop the kids
out of the third storey window where all
three were safely caught by the officers
below this is real life this is IRL
Easley's man catch just the game catch
humans at risk so we're gonna watch this
video there's a huge fire there's a huge
building on fire it's like three stories
high there's the woman and her kids
the mother jump out they eventually they
got a ladder and got her down as well
but I guess the kids were there was a
lot of smoke and they were concerned
about the kids yeah
so here yeah there goes one I love how
many pounds do you think that kid way
dude look at this wow look at the baby
he's grind
poor thing yeah because you just got
[ __ ] out of a window and good on those
guys for catching this baby 2025 so it's
like two and a half stories it's not far
looks smokin like that yeah yeah most
people don't know that in a fire it's
not the fire that kills you but the
smoke right yeah so I did it for the
mother for for actually dropping the
kids out cuz it's like I remember
reading one story a long time ago of a
father who was stuck in the same
situation yeah and he was trying to get
his kids to jump so he decided to
demonstrate it on his own by jumping
first and his kids didn't follow and
they they didn't make it yeah that's
that can be tough so they got a trick so
would you guys so if you guys were in
that situation would you what do you
think you'd be able to successfully
catch the kids I'd be on yourself so I
think I could in the harder question is
would you be able to successfully get
them out the window oh ooh
Gorsky cutting deep I mean if you didn't
underneath a child on child
d-did that with me yeah that would be
but if you're like if you're like at the
window there's a heavy smoke there the
fires in the room next door and it's
like it's pretty good three children
here they're all under three they're
gonna die from smoke inhalation if I
don't get them out right now yeah you
wouldn't have a choice you'd have to
yeah yeah yeah I think it'd be a pretty
good movie I feel like I mean the window
isn't super high up either no it's like
two and a half stories it wasn't three
the first story was like basement level
so the window was right at the ground
yeah those who weren't watching the
video especially there's like multiple
people down there which it looked like
yeah that's see of arms this looks like
Eddie better Joe went off like the
concert stands like from 30 feet to the
crowds yeah yeah Jerry pull it up by
ropes my big bro a big rope ropes always
there right the old the last distributor
of him
so let's say you guys are in this
situation but there are no firefighters
to catch your babies would you still
drop them know this topic is brought to
you by rope this topic brought to you
know because that's like almost certain
death for a child under three yeah
definitely
I'd rather I mean I might I would
probably jump depending on how many
there were
if I had one in my arms I'd probably
jump and try to like cool fall cushion
the fall for them yeah break my legs
then like you know just drop them all
right so all right any others biggest
stage dive ever 1992 so he's just going
from a mother saving her children to
anything his biggest state which is
almost he's like a father to his
children like a concert go around spin
around until you can find it this is a
six minutes long yeah scrubbing through
a constantly starts rub-a-dub-dub scrub
boys
okay so whoa camera crane and jumped
about 20 feet keep scrubbing those who
don't know Eddie Vedder is the lead
singer of Pearl Jam the popular now
house that was 10 feet 15 he's done take
me Jerry Reed Creed is no it's curly
but yeah it's like Christian Pearl Jam
yeah I'm pretty sure Eddie Vetter did
like huge like scaffold I think that was
it you know all right moving on wet
slippery red this is a topic for you
specifically oh really
yeah just ran but the rock singer
version oh wait Nico van it yeah Nico
found a better must crazy must crazy
criminal
on stage must crazy theatrical on stage
any better must crazy was a punk-rocker
any better it be read because here he is
hanging from the underside of a roof of
an awning somehow is the same shirt is
the band just like those of you are
watching these listening only he's
climbing across a 30-foot high stage on
him and a PA is handing him a microphone
now he's hanging from the awning about
30 feet above stage well a PA and a
goofy hat and now he's climbing down a
rope see this is this is not a
microphone cable okay this this episode
brought to you by big cable big cable
that can't be a microphone I think the
microphone would break right yeah
that's strong I mean I think you'd be
surprised I mean they're metal do that
pa7 the time yeah he's having the time
of his life okay this this is just one
highlight he didn't dive alright what a
crazy guy I just knew he had long hair
and he had a deep romantic voice so read
like boy two and a half stories up
[Applause]
the window and all the kids would dive
after it I want to hear about this thing
that yes
so apparently Ren I'm gonna I'm gonna
hyper exaggerate this just like all the
news articles I read about it did
scientists have created a liquid metal
that stretches like the Terminator 1000
now let me explain before you correct
how ridiculous this is American Chemical
Society released a video Wednesday of a
shiny liquid metal that can be
manipulated with magnets it stretches
like the fictional t1000 robot from
Terminator 2 and can also be used to
complete a circuit scientists at the by
Huong University in China led the
research project which added iron
particles to a droplet of gallium indium
and tiny alloy immersed in hydraulic
acid which apparently was able to lower
the surface tension and allow the metal
to be able to stretch and move without
breaking apart so the question is how
far off are we from the t1000 and what
actual advancements could this mean for
humanity so they basically like plastic
metal but before that ran is this legit
I mean what they're doing is legit
hydraulic acid specifically reducing the
surface tension so they can actually
like mold and move this metal without
breaking it because adding like iron
flakes to gallium isn't really that
creative it's like okay it makes sense
so now it'll look like gallium that'll
move like iron doesn't mercury already
do this and isn't mercury a metal but
it's not magnetic okay and so can't
conduct what mercury can't conduct
electricity no it can't yeah being
magnetic and being an electrical
conductor are different things right so
I mean yeah it's like there could be
some creative applications for this I
mean it's not really that much different
than like a ferrofluid which is
basically just a liquid solution of iron
flakes that you can put magnets on they
make that the cool little like yeah
triangular shapes around it and stuff
but why can't some metal be magnetized
and other not I don't know I honestly
don't really know but it's like there's
only just Google that one after the
podcast it's like I forget what the
metals are it's like iron cobalt or is
it one of those weird things in physics
like where we we know what it is but we
don't know why it why it is no no we
know very well all about that it's
probably junk oh it's from like the
electrical fields of all the atoms being
aligned right something like that yeah
yeah actually I think yeah okay so but
my point is do you like is this the
starting point from which we can create
soft robotics and like what is a soft
robot I feel like this is the equivalent
of being like whoa I made a transistor
that means someday we're gonna have
really high quality video games it's
like it's been kind of a big stretch and
a lot of things have to happen between
the two things so really connected
people are only creating this you know
what kind of metal can really stretch
just like a dad joke are you about to
drop right it's just because of the fact
that it's very reflective it's a
chrome-like material that they're able
to move in so it reminds people of the
movie Terminator 2 yeah that's the only
correlation it doesn't mean that it'll
actually create that tightness entire
article is written off of one picture
okay what in your everyday life do you
use that is gooey and stretchy and
amorphous you don't why would you and if
you do what is it
[Laughter]
robotics okay into the Terminator to
extrapolates this with the example of
the t1000 it's a intelligent AI robot
that can take any shape or form
intelligent artificial intelligence it's
an it's AI robot it's an AI robot that
can take any shape or form so the
biggest difference there with that robot
is that it wasn't just a big gooey mess
of metal it was like literally trillions
of nano particles yeah yeah all have
their own separate like brain and they
all are able to work together I mean the
one thing they didn't show you in the
Terminator movie and Terminator 2 it's
like if it got blown apart into enough
pieces it would just be like two smaller
versions of him they're just a bunch of
tiny ones yeah I mean yeah yeah that was
something that was never explored by you
know they did well they did that totally
blew him apart and then he morphed I
know whether but what if they were too
wooden though there's splits in half
Theory just like literally just collapse
into ten different versions of himself
that each weigh 1/10 of Israel go carts
and they go after him with tiny shotguns
we just might be a quarter of a surgeon
alight is two halves or are you talking
about the t1000 if you split hair loss
yeah I'm not sure all of science
questions and as you be right the thing
that would have to be maintained would
just be the weight the mass so it's like
if each one is the mass and it's a
little different because they're metal
so the strength properties are all
different it's like so actually yes he
could just make a shell of himself that
is the same volume as his original self
but he's like maybe Hollow
I think we're getting at I think is a
correction to our previous statement it
wouldn't make to half size t1000 so make
maybe it's slightly under half size
would be slightly over half size when
you say size are you talking my volume
or mass I'm just talking about volume
I'm very about height
is so irrelevant dear listeners or cast
any harsh and the easier they are to
fight if you split the t1000 and a half
maybe 1000 divided proportionately half
into each t1000 how tall would each new
t1000 be talking about hot dog likes
like straight down like an AC T's minus
1/2 exactly half his math goes in math
exactly half of his mass goes into the
two tinier t1000 even proportionally as
he was as a stick to it we're gonna
figure this out don't worry this is next
podcast we come back open it with the
inside he's 6 feet tall he's a mass of
200 pounds right yeah of metal so if you
split him in half
he'd be three feet tall proportionally
exactly the same think so with a mass of
a hundred I don't think why won't he be
half that oh oh my god I think it's
gonna be higher the taller than half his
height actually but you guys hope you're
doing with three dimensions but you took
half the weight and he took and you just
took half the weight out of the original
weight and then you just had that be
exactly proportional to the original
yeah but the distribution of that mass
would be different let me let me provide
you guys an example all right I'm going
to compare my height and weight with the
height and weight of a twelve-year-old
okay okay all right so twelve-year-old
average weighs 91 pounds okay double
that that would equal 182 pounds 182
pounds so maybe more like a
thirteen-year-old for me because I'm
about 190
so either way let's just catch let's
just say it's a twelve-year-old sure
that's average height though of a
twelve-year-old half my weight this is
this is completely irrelevant to what
we're talking about you're talking about
fumin growth trajectory we're talking
about okay but a 12 12 this is son we've
all Sam okay bogus science in order the
point 9 feet tall is not is not your
not nine and a half feet tall now so
what I'm saying is that these two t1
thousands that we create by splitting
their mass in half would most likely be
taller the true answers it's not a
better situation to be in
when it can like shape himself to be
whatever he wants he can theoretically
make himself to be twice as tall right I
need twice as high every condition wait
what probably can't do that why not
because he can't add it no he wouldn't
yet same weight he'd probably just be
hollow in certain parts cuz he can make
himself like why isn't he just a hollow
thirty foot tall James Cameron didn't do
it that's why hold on hold on hold on if
James Cameron didn't do it then it means
that the robot can't do it
because it was never shown in James
Cameron as the auteur of the piece has
decided in that world that the
nanotechnology cannot be hollow it's no
in the world of made-up things well this
is actually like a film writing like we
use this all the time in writing like
once you make a rule you can't break it
otherwise it why okay why can't he have
a hollow cavity if he can make his arm
into a four-foot-long blade because it
grab it and throw it and spike someone
with it because as they didn't what
guess what they weren't showing in that
shot his legs that's right one of his
legs got smaller lose a piece of himself
in that one scene where they get away in
that Lincoln and he has the little like
uh-huh and then Arnold Schwarzenegger
shoots it off with the shotgun and
that's just hanging there and it pops
out on the street and they see how it
was dead and disconnect and then he
walks up to it and absorbs it but he's
not any shorter when he walks up to it
and absorbs it so maybe you have you
have circumstantial evidence for you
question we have your mic on I think
it's really quiet now okay all right but
now it's not quiet anymore I have a
question does hyper jumping ship into a
fleet and destroying the fleet in star
wars from now absolutely not why not
because why are you not gonna think of
that every time they get to a space
battle like why don't they just hyper
jump and leave
I know death by everybody but I really
because of Star Wars is about does this
make it so that any time you watch a
Star Wars space battle from now on
you're like well the diaper jump you're
a sea suicidal kamikazes magically
spiked out and hit all the other space
ships perfectly we've got time for about
two more topic looks cool all right and
I've redone I've got three listed here
can we just agree to never talk about
sores in the podcast I've got a
fanfiction and for Star Wars I think we
can agree to never argue about the the
scientific details of a fictional world
using isn't whether or not it's possible
in the world of Star Wars and whether
follows rules it's more sewer no no as a
viewer does it ruin battle scenes for
you because are you going to be
distracted every time there's a mouse
that hyperjump without like doing
certain stuff to your ship and so if
you're in a middle of a battle you can't
just stop the ship and decide to hyper
jump unless you're crazy like han Solo
so you're getting into the actual
science of it which is again you're
talking about nonfiction in a fictional
universe I'm just talking about as a
viewer it's not gonna be talking about
it I'm not it's no I'm gonna be thinking
why don't they do you're gonna think
about open those there's no air in Star
Wars in space earth sorry there is air
in space in star wars fuse with the
bombing thing they just opened up the
doors you know so I was like this is
just so man oh man go on space and just
like think that they can have like giant
ships fly into the Death Star they're
amazing
open bays and there's like troops
walking walking around in those Bay's
when there could expose those are force
fields oh that reminds me of my favorite
jokes from
my god I did I'm a genius we're talking
Mars game versus Moon gang and they're
getting into a fight in space oh look
it's there just what is worth it's a
really silly idea about weed farmers on
Mars we're seeing it it goes anywhere
that's what it was about anyway I
remember the game elite dangerous yeah I
like how and I don't play that for hours
yeah I like out in the game the reason
you could hear the explosions was as the
computer stimulating it for you inside
the ship so as a computer-generated
explosion noise helps you as a pilot
understand what's going on and if your
cockpit got cracked and all the air got
sucked out then it would take out all
the sound from the computer and you
couldn't hear it anymore
that's attention to people out there
that gets me into space alright let's
talk about uber and literally okay we
all use uber what do you guys use it we
bur our lift lift
uber I like to vote for the underdog
both you use both yes honestly do you
check both and find the cheaper price I
did just a couple days ago really yeah I
mean I used to almost always use uber
just because I didn't have a lift
account but everyone's always like oh
you should go with lyft uber is evil
blah blah so I started actually you know
believing that and sorry I started
trying to well that's not true but I
know I know but like I say people didn't
like their CEO because he was he was a
frat guy right I'm just saying that
that's like that got me into like making
a lyft accountant so now I use both but
I'm just not a yeah I don't want to yeah
okay so we also we have we've all used
boom right there IPOs are coming up and
the question is ultimately they're all
they're continuing to operate at a loss
right throughout all this time what yes
everyone knows this
I don't what yes they're valued at
billions of dollars uber and lift him up
it's an it is known Nico for years uber
and lyft how are you saying they're
upping a loss because I just taking all
the profit they're making and
reinvesting it no that doesn't count
No
they're operating at here so here's the
thing let me just read this from from
the little blurb I wrote I guess at a
loss but Emily they're IPOs at hand
uber and lyft are criticizing our
they're emphasizing that they are
technology companies not transportation
companies and therefore not subject to
most rules for road based businesses so
they say they're a they're a company
that connects millions of transportation
providers to transportation consumers
but in that sense they're only a tech
company and it's like Facebook's a tech
company yeah
and so basically - the whole time in
order to spur this growth and to operate
they've they've if you didn't know you
know their prices were always cheaper
than taxis right which is why they got
which is why they caught on in large
part in the first place as well because
they were significantly cheaper and so
they've they've operated cheaply through
two things number one by operating at a
loss and number two by being classified
as a technology not sure I buy this but
operating at a loss thing because you're
I think you're simplifying what could
very easily be we're making lots of
revenue but reinvesting into things and
the company's spending on stuff well
okay if each ride regardless of that
though Nikko if that's true right at
some point they'll need to show money on
the books for them to have a long term
strategy so regardless of whether or not
they're just operating at a loss on the
books or whether they're truly operating
at a loss is kind of irrelevant to the
fact that as a company that's going
public eventually they'll need to show
numbers that actually show profit in
order for them to be sustainable so what
where I'm going is there's two things
happening right now they're operating at
a loss on paper and two they are
classified as technology companies not
transportation companies I think so I
think that's really the main point here
the regardless of how much money they
are or aren't making right class that is
my first yeah that self assessment I
think is really worth discussing yes so
that's my first question is is is that a
proper like identification and then also
what happens there's they're obviously
super eager to develop self-driving
fleets so is this classification key to
their success long-term and
they can remain as tech companies or
should they be classified as
transportation companies and then also
is self-driving fleets key to their
success long term perhaps rather than
trying to fit a square peg in a round
hole which is just making a new
classification which it would be what a
transportation technology company
transportation networking company no
grinding well that's what they that's
what they that's what they describe
themselves as yes that makes perfect
sense
here's an idea you don't think they
should be subject to Road rules and
stuff like that they're not the ones
operating vehicles the moment they're
operating the vehicles and yes but
they're facilitating the entire economy
sure but they're not they're not just
like they're selling buses let me give
you it let me give you an example back
at you so YouTube shouldn't be liable
for the content it distributes look they
are ubers only could be write another
ten twenty years and then it's good of
you Thomas but then when they just own
huge fleets of self-driving cars that
act as a taxi service in operating cars
then they are a road company but that's
so you think that there's like right now
given you think there because let's see
concrete example guys cuz right now
we're talking about conceptual positive
versus negative effects of uber all
right like think about this are we
talking about Atkins jet like rules and
regulations concerning like congestion
it like I'm just saying high traffic
areas I'm saying they probably they
should probably be classified as a
transportation company because they
provide transportation but what should
they be regulated as like how like
drivers unions and stuff like that or
like are we talking about how they can
oh let's turn them where they can
operate their vehicles it's to a point
now where yes they have they have a
series they have thousands of people so
that aren't quote working for them but
as contractors right and then like at
what point do you cross the line I mean
we've had to deal with this with our own
business we've hired contractors and at
what point do we like okay we should
probably try to have people be employees
rather than contractors because at a
certain point it gets to a point where
you're like okay this is this original
setup which I agree at the onset they
they probably were tech companies but
now like how far does it go before they
become transportation so let me point
out one thing there's that's that's
those are two topics actually I have I
believe there's the topic of the 21st
century gig economy and then there's the
topic of this this uber need to be like
regulated as far as what their cars can
on can and cannot do because that's one
one is we're talking about the people
and oneness we're talking about the
equipment you know what I mean right
can these uber cars are they banned from
certain areas from a federal or state or
local standpoint etc cetera but then the
gig economy is its other topic well we
all increase when do you feel more
strongly about well what I'd like to say
is like we all agree that it provides
something right everyone uses it and so
what's the key to their long-term
success here is it getting away from a
gig economy or is it just simply like
getting changing their fleets to
autonomous self-driving so that they'd
get away with that they get away from
that and they also become transportation
companies I think sounds great
self-driving is fine and honestly I
think promote like a like a like a
roadway standpoint as long as uber
continues to obey the road like the road
laws then there's not much I think
people need to do yes because when it
comes to the actual vehicles themselves
it's like as long as whoever doesn't get
so big they can start like avoiding pain
so you can find imposing congestion okay
so like now that we know that's I think
obviously we okay I agree where are the
right now we're at a point where we say
okay self-driving cars is probably key
to their long-term success they should
go ahead and do that now let me pose
another question should they own that
fleet or should they allow people with
self-driving cars to contribute to that
fleet and continue to skirt around this
I think I think the constant insistence
on taking what's a new structured modern
company and shoehorn it into some old
definition of what a company needs to be
is quite frankly not putting the effort
they need to do to evolve with the world
if uber is a new structure of company so
come up with new structures to deal with
it don't try to shoehorn it into some
old-fashioned notion of oh this is a
technology company or this is a rodeo
company it's obviously a new structure
and you need to create new regulations
and new ways thinking about
how cool would it be to buy a
self-driving car and then like basically
at night you're just like oh you put it
on the rental mode and it just goes off
and makes money for you I mean that's
what people are gonna do and it's gonna
be awesome I mean that's the promise
Tesla has already made yeah so I think
that's super cool there is one thing we
haven't addressed about uber and lyft
and that is the whole like electric
scooter program right now it's all just
bird and uh line and whatnot lyft has
come out and said recently I think it
was lift it might have been hoovered
that brings him to I know I know they do
but they said that they fully expect the
electric scooter sharing program to be
50% of the revenue in the very near
future
really yeah weird cuz it's like or no
just scooters but like bicycles electric
bicycles a personalized electric
mobility is what they see is the future
of their new street with these guys I
feel like what's gonna actually happen
here is very shortly people are gonna
wisen up to the fact that you don't have
to be a burr or lyft to have people like
use your stuff and like you're gonna see
lots and lots of like little homegrown
like equivalence of uber and lyft
popping up for like heyy Bike Share you
can go here and you can rent like my e
bike and like every can sign up and
we'll all get a cut well you're gonna
see a lot of copycats and I thinking to
see over and lift using government
regulations to kill their competition in
a very anti-capitalistic way we're
already seeing that you see what Santa
Monica right now uber and lyft sorry I
don't mean to cut you off ago real quick
uber and lyft lobbied the Santa Monica
government said yeah these birds are a
public nuisance you need a company's
gonna work with you guys for a
regulation for a good safe neighborhood
so you guys should ban all companies
except for ours we will be the ones to
provide and they agreed to that and
[Music]
small businesses go except for the
entire city of San Francisco and instead
of being like only us they they
basically manage to bait like ban all
electric scooters and holdin basically
an audition process in general even
companies that share them you can own
your own and still go around but like so
they had they holding like an audition
process essentially to reel ow only like
three or four different companies back
in yeah at the time they were like does
I said how are see you're not allowed
store your vehicle on the public
sidewalk that's what I'm thinking works
like that new sense of like I love the
convenience factor with him with touring
is about all I yeah but ultimately just
yeah I think that's what everyone really
hates like I'm sure those people don't
probably hate the ride-sharing itself
it's the they don't like to have to like
walk around the scooters businesses try
this if the scooters and whatever other
forms of Transpo they want to have are
stored in a private area that's anybody
should be okay for then anyone should be
able to do it and it's the exact same
thing as cars mm-hmm you store your car
where you're allowed to either on the
street so either this either the
sidewalks have special areas allocated
for public parking of vehicles personal
vehicles or you store it in a private
area where you have a full right to park
it other than that everyone's allowed to
use the road storing them on the public
storing them in public areas without
regard to like there being a stated area
for that I think guys is a huge problem
and then I can see a city or any other
governments stepping and be like you
can't just put your stuff in this right
but then they should go okay let's let's
mark off these parking spots with pink
paint and you can park them there or
maybe just you know make people want to
run a private business talk to various
private individuals to store it yeah you
storm in a parking because there's
plenty of parking lots that would allow
you to park in a spot kind of a dumb
question how long does it thing have to
sit around for you to be able to take it
legally no that's like the essence of
common law right there man that's how
like laws are made like how long though
so how long does the bird scooter have
to sit on the sidewalk before I can take
it oh I'm just gonna take it no no
that'd be two years two years yeah in
California it sits there for two years
the property for teachers so let me get
this straight you didn't regain you
didn't abandon it right it's still owned
by the person like a bird scooter I mean
there's a so you're saying there's a
difference if I'm like I'm done with the
scooter and you don't say that and I
just throw it on the sidewalk
well that's your inattention and you
abandoned the property then whoever
picks it up next at below
I never said was it like I actually
still wanted that two years later well
no then that would be circumstantial
what if you park your scooter in a spot
and no one happens to touch it and you
don't have to touch it how long does it
need to sit in that spot until you
relinquish ownership of it you didn't
say anyone knows no then it's in it
where is it parked just on the side of
the street it's on the public it's on a
sidewalk no then then then you haven't
abandoned the property but your actions
have indicated to others that it's
abandoned so there's some ambiguity
there so a lady highly circumstantial in
an in a situation where there's so
there's this there's it's called
conversion basically in the law and so
like this is what happened with that
sword
that Brandon made for that Oh for the
right and medical and Medicare solid
video so that he made a he borrowed are
made of metal gear solid sword and the
agreement was that the company would own
the sword but they never came for it so
he he just held onto it with openly
letting everyone know like hey I'm
holding on to this he put it up in his
studio this is a perfect example of
conceited in every node video but you
see it in every node video and and
eventually the makers of that game never
came back and claimed it so conversion
law a lot like takes advantage of the
fact that at a certain point if
something's not claimed it should go to
others that they can utilize it and so
then as through conversion that became
Brandon's how long does that conversion
take it's two years okay
generally for most things so he's had
that sort for a lot longer yeah
obviously by that but like if you just
parked your scooter so like after 10
minutes circumstances probably say well
that's probably not you how about how
you haven't abandoned that property
because maybe you just went in like it
comes down to what a reasonable person
in the same situation would think and do
is what it comes down to so if you saw
somebody drop a scooter on the side of
the sidewalk and then you walked in to a
building like you wouldn't go up and be
like well they abandon the scooter it's
mine now you clearly think well they
went in there to do something and
they'll be back for it or even if it's
like 24 hour almost
24 hours or more once again once you hit
over 24 hours and it's going yes exactly
so once the person starts to think
scooter just sitting there I feel like
if you have a scooter you want it with
you at all times but it's funny because
this is how the law would actually
function in this capacities they would
look at the facts and be like well what
a person after 48 hours start to think
are you coming back for that sure now we
have to get that person who's scooter it
is clearly right there at gourmet Kenny
if they're filing something because did
you make any effort to contact the
person or knock on the door and what was
a person doing yeah were they minding
their own business but after like a week
did they go on vacation after a week
after two week cuz they move to a new
city it's probably abandoned after two
weeks yeah for a scooter for sure but
somewhere in between there you don't
really know and so that's the weird
thing with that although the intention
of the company is to specifically leave
them out for yes but everybody here's
the difference everyone knows that
they're not there for free and they're
locked and it requires an app program
with money together you can't take them
cuz everyone knows everyone knows that
they're not ma'am everyone knows that
they're not a band or not for in devote
not for individual use no it's it comes
down to whether or not it's a band and
everyone knows that's not abandoned
property yeah exactly so that's why you
can't take them and they have GPS so
they know they'd get in trouble if they
did well yeah but if you mistakenly
thought that they were abandoned if you
were like a pygmy and you showed up and
you were like oh sick mean a scooter
like without any knowledge of like how
the law or anything you wouldn't be
liable for larceny because you didn't
have the intent to steal you thought it
was abandoned property but eventually
the GPS system would show up and they'd
be like hey that's our [ __ ] scooter
yeah give it back deep reverences all
right well that's kind of I mean I got a
couple more if you guys want to get into
some some hairy [ __ ] but color great you
just got a color grade Sam's got to edit
yeah it's that time it's
so ding-dong boys happy Friday it's not
Friday it's Thursday oh yeah but by the
time the people like this Friday having
these conversations on topics hash tag
ropes hash tag big rope it's a big ropes
fault
yeah sorry it's one thank you guys for
listening and taking part in this
discussion with us it's absolutely right
and if you guys are listening to audio
only podcasts consider doing it on cast
box where you can find corridor cast as
well as every other one of your favorite
podcasts I'm gonna check that one out
yeah yeah it's good it's a little app
you can download it and listen away
Kelly please consider subscribing to the
quarter cast channel if you haven't
already and please consider hitting that
little bell icon we're sharing our
notifications if you are a person who
enjoys notifications for good videos
ring-a-ding-ding
ring-a-ding-ding that bellboys yeah oh
also please tell me if you took the
t1000 pounds and you split them in half
into two 100 pound t1 thousands and they
had the same proportions as the six-foot
tall one how tall well I'd love to see
the math yeah no I agree with Nika I
want to say feel free to do the
equations with any any weight liquid
metal waves a Google spreadsheet so you
don't get any numbers you want 200
pounds it's not going to change six feet
tall yeah 1000 pounds 6 feet tall and if
you wonder how wide how six foot tall
man 200 pounds X foot tall - you want
that I'm sorry this way you have a 1
foot by 1 foot by 1 foot cube it weighs
100 pounds
how big where are the dimensions of a
cube that weighs 50 pounds ok there it
is alright that's the exact same reason
that's freaking you just slowly turned
down
yeah I would have one spoon and then
another say